yo it's your buddy josh can't wait for
you to check out this clip it's from a
special that i shot over quarantined in
front of a
socially distanced masked 20-person
crowd so if you can't hear the crowd
imagine how i felt
love this material can't wait for you to
check it out watch the whole special
father time later everybody
some things don't change about kids like
they're still really gross
jacob used to sit next to me hand does
he have his hand in his pants a lot
hand in his pants just
and i'd be eating chips and he'd reach
for it i'd be like what what are you
he was like oh on some chips like
your hands
were they were on your hand was on your
nuts
he was like so like
your nuts are dirty
and he goes no they're not they've been
in my pants all day and i was like
i don't have a good argument for that i
guess you want to chip like i don't know
i mean but he said it like on most days
he's dragging him around the ground he's
like look at my nuts you know
they're gross
they've started taking those long
showers did he take the long showers you
know he took long showers man here's the
thing we're sitting in the living room
and beth was like why is he taking those
long showers she must be really dirty
i'm like mom he's dirty
and she said i go do you want to know
why he's taking long showers and she
goes
no
so i finally had to tell him man
i said hey i don't want to tell you that
i know what's happening in there
but i know what's happening in there and
he goes i don't know what you're talking
about don't make me say it to your face
dude
and he goes i don't know what you say
are you okay
i'm gonna ask you not to masturbate in
the shower and he was like dad i can't
believe you said that to me i'm like i'm
just trying to tell you i don't mind you
masturbating but why do i gotta pay for
it like with a hot water bill is crazy i
don't know anybody that pays for their
kid to jerk off i'm not gonna be one of
them you know what i mean so do it on
your own time brother you know what i'm
saying
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]